let's talk about the future and not the
past we got this story from texas
tribune capital police dismissed texas
congressman troy nels's accusation that
he's been illegally investigated this is
very interesting so we have this tweet
from troy nels where he says that
he was his office i think was the 20th
of november last year
was uh was broken into illegally by
capital police special agents who
photographed legislative materials that
are protected under the constitution the
what is the what is the provision the
speech special debate clause speech and
debate clause and they were
photographing it came back a few days
later and interrogated one of his staff
members over what the photo was here's
what gets interesting and that's a very
very bold and terrifying accusation that
that
capitol police have expanded into an
intelligent intelligence agency and are
going after critics of the january 6
committee as is troy nels
now the capitol police came out with a
statement saying
we were uh just uh
doing our job and noticed his door was
open and uh we decided to see what was
going on and that's all they said they
didn't address the fact that troy nels
said they were dressed as construction
workers or that they had photographed
privy uh materials
and the capital the capital police
didn't bring that up which is strange
because the story we have now is troy
nell says capitol police broke into my
office
violated the constitution dressed as
construction workers and interrogated my
staff it's all illegal and they went
we did go into his office
and it's like okay so you're confirming
that part of the story we went in his
office was this all at once did they
interrogate no there's somebody's
dressed as construction workers
apparently that would be history are you
serious that's what he said oh my gosh
my point is the capitol police issued no
statement as to whether they were
dressed as construction workers insane
why they were taking photographs all
they've said is
a portion of what he said is true so
they didn't die so so as far as i'm
concerned there's no denial and a
partial confirmation that this is
happening this is this is
look guys
civil war level stuff when capital
police have expanded into into an
intelligence agency where there is a
weaponized a political faction one of
them in the country has weaponized law
enforcement in this country to go after
one look january 6 defendants get
solitary for a year blm gets nothing
january 6
nancy pelosi doesn't allow any actual
conservatives or republicans on the
committee to actually have a real debate
and investigation what's going on they
empower only their cronies adam
kinzinger who thinks he's actually in
line with republicans it's bipartisan no
it's not he hates trump he hates all of
these people he smack talks to them all
day liz cheney the same thing they were
both just centered by the republicans we
have one establishment uniparty faction
using law
law enforcement to target anyone who
opposes them this is dark stuff
i mean it's actually i don't know i see
it as sort of indicative of potential
like
you know break a blow up of the
separation of powers and i'll explain
right like historically and if you
actually look around the world most
countries don't do the kind of separated
uh legislative and executive branch
thing like that's not very common in
most structures most of them have a
simple parliamentary system
right and and that and that's true even
though those parliaments didn't emerge
as like the most powerful institution
like thing about england right like
there was the king there was the house
of lords now it's literally the house of
commons and the prime minister and
that's the government well they still
have lords and it's like so this is one
of this is one of the ways like the the
congress sort of expanding its own
authority and in a way like if the
capital police has expanded its own
authority and taking on law enforcement
role that it doesn't have under our
constitution
then and you know you have the january 6
commission essentially doing like a
full-scale prosecution of everybody
involved in the trump thing except
without ge going after trump's
they're going after a former president
his staff
media personalities that it is insane
it is horrible um
but i you know one thing michael malus
says a lot is that the white pill is how
stupid our opponents are and can you
imagine you're just doing your job in
some fed dressed as a construction
worker comes stupid i was like hey have
you done anything illegal it's like who
are you what is this thanks for asking
look it's such a bizarre strategy i
certainly think that michael uh is right
in a variety of ways they are really
dumb people but stupid people can start
fires that grow out of control true kill
a lot of people so i look at it a couple
ways we saw that happen for a whole
summer i think right i think the end
result of a lot of this is
you know things will become more
localized um the worst case scenario
results in you're going to have your
freedoms living in the middle of nowhere
fractured federal authority means no
more atf coming to your house and
shaking you down over your guns or
whatever so it will benefit a lot of
regular people a lot of ways i think
mostly rural living people who already
have a lower cost of living and are more
personally responsible have chickens and
grow their own food are certainly going
to be better off cities are going to be
in very serious trouble
but uh i will say this
michael malus also talks about peaceful
divorce ron perlman the actor lil donnie
meme guy uh recently said that
republican states should break away from
the rest of us
you see here here's the big point about
you can call your opponent stupid they
certainly call the other both sides call
each other stupid for sure there is no
such thing as a peaceful divorce there
is no such thing as the states shaking
hands and saying adios buddy because
what people need to understand about the
civil war the first time is that seven
states said oh i believe it was seven i
could be wrong had already seceded from
the union before conflict broke out
but what happens the the the union the
federal government says hey you know
that military base you got on your
property that we paid for that's a
resource that belongs to us and we're
not gonna let you keep it and then south
carolina was like we don't care if you
think it's yours it's in our territory
not yours
say fight absolutely so if there ever
was a quote-unquote peaceful divorce
just like we had a partial peaceful
divorce before the civil war kicked off
into full-scale warfare you would have
california and illinois new york and
they'd be like we're going to join
canada or whatever and then all the
republican states will be like fine do
what you want and then there would be a
pause
and then once they would be like
hey those nukes you got over there yeah
we want them you shouldn't be able to
have those and they'd be like we're
keeping them they're like well we're the
legitimate federal government we want
those back well you can't have them
fighting breaks out yeah and so and i've
heard softer versions of it that won't
work either i mean i think there's a
basic problem here which is i don't know
how you could look at the events of the
last two to three years and think that
the left doesn't
very much want to govern the right and
he's not going to let the right leave
and but think about this too sorry
interrupt but uh california's water
comes from the colorado river so you've
got multiple states down there that are
dependent on this water if there was a
breaking up of any of these states
you're gonna have resource wars you're
gonna have one state being like yo we
need water to live and they're going to
be like too bad you need to negotiate a
treaty with us and they're going to be
like or i have weapons and i'll take it
yeah no i think that's a really fair and
accurate assessment but i'd also say on
the other side of it
i don't know if it's possible for two
groups who are as different as the left
and right are currently to remain
together without things breaking out
into violence so whether there's a
divorce or there isn't i think we're
gonna see some pretty catastrophic
outcomes not to be too black-pilled on
that what do you think about like the uh
oh sorry if you're gonna finish well
yeah and also like you said one thing
we've learned over the past uh two years
i would say you can also really observe
this by going even deeper into history
is that the left is absolutely not
interested in leaving the right alone
and i've said this before i think it is
because people who fail to cultivate
virtue cannot stand the sight of people
who have generally speaking and they
feel a need to change them i'm not
saying all right wing people are
virtuous but i am saying with the the
virtues that the left privileges are
basically all forms of degeneracy and
someone who's trying to convince
themselves that those things are good
even though they know deep down they
aren't are going to hate people who they
see living their lives as a positive
example but you know what people like
when they hear you degeneracy
i can simplify that very much for you
sheamus
misery loves company exactly yes
absolutely absolutely what do you guys
think about a union of the united states
and canada
what about it like uh i'll take alberta
but the rest of canada like those people
are amazing i feel like they're my
brothers it's it's as if they're uh us
it's like the same there's so many
resources
not a fringe minority but the minority
right there are so many resources in
canada untapped right now and when the
future comes and we need them someone's
going for them it'll probably be the
canadians but they're gonna be like help
so so you you have the 14 original
colonies
14
because quebec did not join for in
independence so it could have been 14
colonies they were colony of of britain
and they said no we're good so uh when i
look at canada yo
these are the people that were like
we're actually cool with being ruled by
despots and the rest of us were like we
are not unfortunately most people are
sheep ninety percent of the population
of populations probably just gonna go
along with the government and these
united states were started uh
principally by people who are like i do
not think you have a right to to
subjugate me in this way and i will
stand up for my rights and canada was
was primarily a country that said we're
cool with being under the crown man we
don't want we don't want to fight
so that's you can see how that manifests
in our countries canada is very woke
very progressive the conservatives in
canada are authoritarian and progressive
in america we got guns everywhere
because we're like yo don't tread on me
i swear i'll tell you what because we
are the children we are the descendants
of people who said don't tread on me
whereas canada are the descendants of
people who said i'm cool with being
tread on it's fine i'd like to bring the
constitution of the united states to the
canadians and create a new government
you don't even need a single leader it
doesn't have to be like that it can be
like a decentralized union it's time
they have a constitution that's very
similar to us a lot of ways it doesn't
matter we can both adapt our
constitutions together cultural
enforcement is everything if the
canadian people are unwilling to stand
up for things then the culture will not
allow or tolerate for for those things
in the united states we are we had a
culture war and i think the culture wars
effect is over completely over the
culture war i think started at the end
of the 2000s and it became very
prominent with independent media around
the early 2010s we saw gamergate and
things like that it came to a major
crash with the election of donald trump
in the election of 2020 and now the
culture war in my opinion is is over and
we moved into a if i was actually going
to map it out i'd say at some point
maybe after trump got elected cold civil
war emerged and i don't know exactly
when it was probably maybe 2019 maybe it
was 2020.
what i mean to say is there was a period
of gathering the troops
for for a while people were producing
media and saying side with us our side
is right we are so far past that point
now you literally just it's like either
you
the bridge is broken there's no
connection between either faction in
this country there was a period where
people could agree on some things but
fundamentally disagreeing a lot a lot of
others and that snapped we're at the
point where if someone on the quote
unquote right comes out and says the sky
is blue the left will be like it's not
blue you [ __ ] it's actually a lighter
shade of a mix of purple and
this two plus two equals five you've
literally got them saying two plus two
equals five simply because they were
criticized like they were accused of
being like 1984.
if one faction comes out and says that
the other side disagrees and the same
thing is true with masks this thing
really the mass thing pisses me off
because conservatives were four masks
initially then all of a sudden it
flipped and the left was four masks and
now you've got people literally telling
me well if the left says to do it i'll
do the opposite i'm like right that that
says to me we're
not in the culture war is over there are
two distinct cultures that are present
in this country you could say the bridge
is broken but that doesn't mean you
can't build new bridges
i i i
don't think it's possible to build a new
it's possible it's just not easy i i
think you're wrong i i i think it's like
the most likely outcome is not some sort
of peaceful separation it's just one
side of this faction kind of prevailing
right now that either um well no
look you know you donald trump got what
75 million votes or whatever and uh
you've got a parental red wave coming
it's it's a it's a it's a split and so
if you end up with right right now
you've got democrats uh filing a lawsuit
to make it so that madison cawthorn
can't run for re-election this is one of
the most dangerous things that could
ever possibly happen because if the
republicans
vote for madison cawthorne to win and
then the democrats sue and say he's an
insurrectionist who can't hold office
and it goes to a democrat judge who says
i agree because that's literally how the
courts are handling things right now if
you're a democrat you win if you're a
republican you lose then what happens
when madison kawhorn shows up in dc and
says i'm the dually elected
representative from you know i think
it's north carolina right and they say
uh the capital police officer goes no uh
you've been disqualified
then what happens what happens to the
the people of that district who said
you know 70 or whatever percent were
like we voted for this guy how are you
gonna tell us we don't get to have the
guy we voted for you're gonna see it's
gonna it's it's breaking it's breaking
down the mere fact that they're trying
to do it and madison cost hawthorne had
to file a countersuit saying he does
have the right to run shows you we are
not talking about elections anymore
power is not being won in the seat of
government by people saying i hereby
choose this man to represent me it's
being won by powerful special interests
who are funneling money into super pacs
who can go after prominent media who can
go after politicians and destroy them
through procedure and process instead of
the actual electoral process
when that happens and it's happening now
we do not have a constitutional republic
of duly elected reps who are bringing
our interests to dc we have powerful
monied tribal interests
asserting
what they can and can't do and it starts
with them breaking into the office of a
republican dressed as construction
workers it starts with a january 6
committee filing subpoenas against
members of the media whether you like
them or not costing them minimum a
hundred thousand dollars to to to comply
with this garbage it is beyond insane
now now i'm i'm just gonna i'm gonna
keep this grant going in 2018 i said the
street violence was going to escalate
into civil war and people who are who
are too short-sighted said how could
that ever possibly happen you're wrong
tim it won't happen and i said when the
culture war reaches the highest levels
of government it doesn't matter what you
think the united states is capable of
doing when one military branch opposes
the other when one political party is at
odds with the other and they view each
other as fundamentally criminal evil
liars that's how it starts that's how
civil war happens we are literally at
the point where the january 6 committee
is filing subpoenas and in trying to
imprison
members of the previous administration
come 2022 if the republicans win do you
think democrats are going to be like a
good game everybody we see the american
people uh have agreed that you're the
right leadership for this country of
course not absolutely you think they'll
they won't give up their office
no i think they have no idea dude look
at what they're doing with uh
with january sex committee
alex jones is on video saying do not go
in the capital what did they do they
subpoena him costing him a hundred
thousand dollars they have powerful
moneyed interests
launching lawsuits against them and
trying to destroy everything about him
look at joe rogan it was a democrat
political action committee that was
pushing this video to force rogan to
apologize and to try and take his
showdown these are powerful political
interests and they are using every
procedural
law fair tactic they can to cause
problems
it's escalated beyond just political
action and culture war issues when
democrats used the power of law
enforcement to go after regular
americans like that woman in alaska who
had nothing to do with january 6 she was
at a rally for them to start claiming
anyone who supported the president at a
rally unrelated to the capital riot is
now an insurrectionist who can't hold
office
the the gates of civil war have been
opened
okay now the states are are are uh we're
seeing geographical polarization based
on vaccine policy and restriction
we're seeing people flee blue states to
red states like like texas and florida
geographical polarization is happening
ideological polarization has already
solidified the next thing we're going to
see and that worries me is if they start
disqualifying people like marjorie
taylor green lauren bobert madison
hawthorne which they are literally
trying to do right now
what do you think the maga movement of
75 million people is going to say when
they're like sorry the candidates you
you elected are no longer allowed to go
to congress yo people are going to lose
it
it's like basically being told by one
side
you do not get representation in this
country well if you deny the american
people representation and say they're no
longer a part of the system why would
they view you as part of their system
either and then you'll start getting
stuff like what happened with the bundys
you'll get right-wing groups saying if
our rep isn't being is it like you know
lauren bobert colorado if they don't
allow her to run or they disqualify her
they're going to be like well if you
don't recognize us you are not
legitimate we're we're blocking these
roads we're taking over
it's one step at a time no no taxation
without representation yeah i mean
ultimately i i would predict that those
lawsuits would fail thankfully because i
i mean i don't know how dramatic the i
mean i could see it being a really
really bad situation kind of like what
you're articulating if you know they've
managed to exclude like 10 or so
republican conferences
i agree with you i think it is likely to
fail it's an insane prospect i will say
first it can't happen here opt get the
optimism and normalcy bias out of there
everyone has always said this the people
who stayed behind in world war ii
germany who are like ah it's not going
to happen and then it did but the other
thing i'll say is
one side is going to lose this fight the
left or the right do you think either
side will accept defeat do you think if
these left-wing democratic establishment
people who say madison cothward is an
insurrectionist do you think they're
gonna sit back and be like well he's in
congress now he's the one passing the
abortion ban bill after roe v wade gets
overturned by the supreme court they're
gonna be like he's illegitimate he was
sued and it was a republican judge
or whatever
yeah so i think to
piggyback off of points that both of you
made earlier uh you were you were saying
that you think this is going to end with
one side dominating the other you are
saying that you think it's basically
going to break out into civil war
i would argue and maybe this is a little
too pessimistic but
at some point it's just inevitable that
there is going to be some level of
violence because even if it doesn't
break out into a full-on civil war what
you're sort of talking about with one
side lording over the others basically
as orwell put it just a boot stomping a
face so you just end up having violence
from the state against ordinary people
who are just trying to live their lives
peacefully people get pulled in thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time